it's time for roses and Rose a hi you
guys it's me Lauren Zima and I'm
thinking about maybe shooting this
entire video this way because I feel
good about myself from here and then
here they I have a friend I have got the
biggest sit on my face who knew I
birthed a child
no thank you oh my god it's a it's a
little horn on the side of my face the
devil is real well so what am I wearing
what am I wearing I look like a li
somebody said I didn't make a stars burn
reference last video so there it is I
look like a li but also a Real Housewife
of New Jersey this is a rough look you
know what else was rough this week's
episode of The Bachelor and I don't mean
rough like I didn't like it I mean rough
like oh my god can these women exhaust
coltan anymore
I felt like Colton was working hard this
episode you guys
he's moving her falling apart he had to
keep putting him back together and
they're breaking down and he had to keep
lifting him up and they're crying and
had to keep wiping away those tears did
you feel like the ladies were on a
dramatic role this episode and Gordon
was just having to slow their roll yeah
they were dropping like flies right tell
me what you thought of the app and let's
get into it
first of all oh my god this like feels
like forever ago at this point I forgot
sick on yoga and Nicole were still
fighting because we were left on the to
be continued and I just don't care me
myself and I don't care about on yoga
and Nicole anymore and guess what
they're going on by E they're both sent
home in the rose ceremony Wow Colton not
messing around what did you guys think I
kind of love MIDI sent both of them home
see you later alligator why did I just
say that whoopsie daisies it's a Notting
Hill reference
yeah yesterday's is no one whose dig
whoopsy daisies for what fifty years I
kind of thought I was gonna get a little
bit more time with Colton tonight but uh
naked Nicole kept going at it
heishi was like complaining that she
didn't get any time because of Aigner
chemicals drama and it's like girl LOL
okay move on with the no time thing at
this point we are done with no time
there's no time for no time everybody
gets their time if they try to get their
time okay time is precious that you'll
never get back so don't mess around with
it that's why I'm constantly drinking
and this glass was given me today by
let's see if I was told that I could
give a shout out to who this was from
Kelly Danny direct Oh says and it was
made by Shay Gagne Thank You shegaon yay
for this glass that says self-care on it
you know who we care about ourselves
yes it's an important message I love it
I really do take care of yourself
I'll take care of you too
at the rose ceremony by the way somebody
whispered how many roses are there and I
just get that because math is hard I
related Anna Cole made the sign of the
Cross and like that's tough you know
that was tough for her to just be
invoking the Lord to help her through
this rose ceremony a lot of tough
moments at the beginning here don't
drink every time it's tough because then
dummy is said it's my greatest pleasure
to accept this is as much as what I love
Demi that was weird that was tough and
then you know Nicole is crying and I'm
you get Nicole or leaving yeah I don't
know it's just Nicole's crying a lot and
it's tough and it was tough to watch on
Jaeger still complaining about Nicole it
all just felt so penny we're past this
okay bye mmm we need a new location we
need a new vibe and guess what the show
knows what we need and so we they gave
it to us and so we went to Hannah G is
getting a one-on-one that's exciting
because we've been talking about how we
want to see more know more about Hannah
G right and then Sydney makes the
comment that it seems as though people
who go on one-on-ones come back way
further along in their relationships
than the rest of us have we seen the
show I feel like I'm saying this every
week with one of the women it's like
have you seen the show let me see the
show watch the show if you don't want to
watch the show watch roses in rows a
just so you feel prepped consider this
you know a CliffsNotes
instead of taking the whole course every
time I see her I get most men
Colten and Hannah's date guys is cool
like a little goobers sometimes you know
he's a little goober II sometimes drink
every time Colton's a bit of a goober
and I say that with love sometimes he
just is
he tells Hannah nobody else I'd rather
be wrapped up cuz they're getting
massages and wraps also a little
confusing to me because I think we're
getting to that point where he's kind of
saying pretty serious things to each of
the women and I'm having a hard time
telling who he really is into are you
guys feeling that way like he seems
really into Taoiseach but also he had
that really intense date with Cassie and
now he's telling Hannah there's no one
he'd rather be wrapped up with and he
says he would eat that sushi roll I
would definitely eat that sushi roll
okay is that goober you're just too much
would you guys want a guy to tell you
that I'm gonna say no insanity okay
thank you
don't drink every time they make out why
do they love to kiss I'm glad to see
another outdoor shower very on Brandon
for this season no matter what country
we're in we're getting you an outdoor
shower
I feel of an outdoor shower you're gonna
shower an outdoor shower it's great you
got to be in the Sun I love the Sun I do
have a vitamin D deficiency though so I
need to it's too much why my doctor's to
shut up mm-hmm
anyway Hannah and golden are at dinner
and don't drink every time was falling
apart at the seams
[Music]
these are horrible why am i I'm so sorry
for wearing these so Hannah and Colton
are at dinner and don't drink everytime
they say good it's very good freakin
spit out my wine because it starts
talking about how much they love you out
there shower
what is your very favorite part shower
shower shower is pretty good who
wouldn't
what do you guys think like knowing what
we know about Colton now is he somebody
you'd want to date are you super
attracted them tell me what you think
back to the women though they are
wherever they are and Corpus chin man
they disappeared so that's great and she
doesn't seem to have any kind of a mark
so great we don't know how it got better
but whatever Cassie and they have it
reads the date card and I just want to
say shout out to all the girls and
glasses we're seeing the women hang with
each other in their glasses this season
more than ever before and as a woman who
is maybe even legally blind I might be
I'm not sure I would contact lenses in
my prescriptions an 8.5 what are you
guys that I'm pretty fine so shout out
to the ladies and glasses I appreciate
it Heather reads the date card and
Sydney and Demi are both upset and both
kind of crying without tears
did you believe Sydney and Emmys tears
this is my sixth group date so I'm
really over them at this point we get a
group date the group date is one of
those days where I worry about the
liability and the insurance of it all I
guess they're gonna be fighting each
other seems pretty good at karate so
shout out to karate but okay it's not
karate it's called I wrote down Volvo
town but there's no way that's right
so JC is probably gonna have to go back
and figure out what it is the ancient
art difficutly Fox I don't know what
it's called it's some kind of fighting
practice thing but I would never be
involved in I'm ready to get after it
so we're competing in this sport now
that's the date I see all these conclave
moves I'm thinking
yeah could we have gotten the judges a
bigger table we're just a bunch of them
crammed at this little table and just
kind of funny to me I wanted to do some
friend of mine before we get started I
love when Chris Harrison gives the
chance to sports cast this time with the
host of The Bachelor Vietnam and they
are holding mics that are definitely not
plugged into anything or working at all
purely for show coming up on The
Bachelor might as well been doing this
then I have something to drink and then
everyone is participating in Voldemort
iam no that's different thing is
definitely not fighting it's like fight
snuggling and kind of like girl fighting
but also snuggling this is so funny
because how he sees Heather's hair like
dummy's really getting upset and really
getting hit then he's got a big bark but
not a lot of bite she got her butt
kicked Heather and Sydney are fighting
they've got to be like replaying
whatever noise that was don't drink
every time you heard that noise that is
happening during them fighting
they definitely replayed that so anyway
I don't know none of that went well so
cold wait let's go to the after-party we
have an after-party to get to what do
you say we get on out here we gotta get
out of here we got to move forward you
just stepped forward and said we got to
move forward one on ones other one said
I'd kill for every single day and drink
every time Colton makes a serious
statement to one of these women
he tells tisha that he just kills for
their one-on-ones and again I'm just
kind of confused on who he's really into
at this point who do you guys think
Colton is the most obsessed with right
now
I just haven't said to myself to be
honest
how are you feeling right now scared now
we get to what I was referencing earlier
which is that Colton spends so much of
this episode reassuring everyone it's
very exhaustive to me like I mean he had
to reassure Katy and now he has to
reassure Sidney and is there a reason
why you're not putting me on Aman Aman
drink every time Colton has to reassure
someone tonight don't think for a second
I don't think you're not trying I'm
still working through this I'm still
navigating us I'm good I'm trying I'm
trying I
the man has to be emotionally exhausted
at this point in the game but you know
what he still manages to say I forgot
that we started off this journey with
Demi by finding out that her mom was in
federal prison
okay but as a reminder she was in but
now she's out and Demi decides that she
is going to have her first normal phone
call I've had with my mom in years with
Colton on the line would you guys have
done this and we not have done this
doesn't seem fair to mom it seems like a
big emotional moment that's true and
real between a parent a child I'm not
sure I would have done it on The
Bachelor just saying what do you think
you let me know I don't know was I wrong
yeah would you have done it tell me what
your opinions on it hi mommy she calls
her mom and she's like I've been missing
you mom I'm worried about you and I'm
proud of you for like getting through
everything there was a lot of subtext
there wasn't it wasn't a lot of subtext
so I just mean again no judgment I mean
we don't know the whole story here and
god I sure hope that that woman is that
women tell all
I would love to see her there fresh out
of lockup free and you know they had a
phone called The Bachelor what a way to
come back into life what a way to come
back into everyday society phone call
with The Bachelor you know from Vietnam
I don't think he's very happy and
I think she's taking this as seriously
as she can Wow there's these other girls
that seem to be taking this super
lightly heishi is saying that the other
girls seem to be taking this super
lightly I just don't know what the
evidence of this is is they cut to Demi
kind of laughing in a weird way I don't
think that the women are taking this
more lightly than they have in any
seasons past I don't know what do you
guys think is there someone on the show
a contestant who you feel isn't taking
this seriously at this point I just
anymore and I think I can get more out
of this from you and from us
okay so Sydney needed her reassurance
but I guess it wasn't enough
poor Colton he tried you were taking a
lot of easier choices with the people
that you are pursuing and Sydney tells
Colton she's leaving I am gonna go home
[Music]
my mind was kind of blown by this I did
not see this coming did you I liked
everything that she told him she said
look I don't think we can get there it's
just easier for us to go our separate
ways and I thought it was a mature
conversation if you want to go girl
that's fine but she does help cool me
don't be distracted by shiny things
aka referring to someone in the rest of
the women who are here and I thought
that was shady and I don't think that
Sydney needed to throw that shade as she
left one who do you guys think she was
talking about and to do you think that
that was wrong of her to say it just
felt mean to me like I don't know I just
don't think that there are any women
left here who were like that's
superficial honestly I kind of like
everybody who's left so didn't feel fair
to me wasn't walking Colton's walking
Constance Walker
Katie gave us one of my favorite moments
of the night when she sounded like a
Secret Service agent for no GD reason
and went Golden's walking Colton's
walking closer
the eagle has landed in the henhouse the
eagle is in the henhouse he's landing in
the henhouse
[Music]
the alligator is underneath the alley
the alligator underneath the alley
underneath it Ali and Jackson aren't at
the grammys Ali and Jackson are at the
Grammys
[Applause]
Taoiseach we accept this for us so
Colton gives taste of the rose and oh my
god an abuse face she's like it's like
the look of someone who couldn't be less
happy for the other person I will see
you all soon all right so cold leaves
the rose ceremony and someone says he's
not in the happy-go-lucky typical cold
sea of smiling mood that I've seen him
in most days of course he doesn't look
happy
you people have freakin exhausted him
with your need for reassurance and
emotional support he's tired so I'm
interested to see if she'll come home
today come back we'll see perp against a
one-on-one so excited for her she's
healed her face and she's moving forward
I wasn't expecting it oldest I'm gonna
get a break here because freakin kirpa
is already crying ten seconds into the
date girl
ah you've been somebody who throughout
all of this every single week we've
continued to like not only like
progressed forward would take like leaps
and bounds like every time I leave my
time with you I take something away he
then starts saying that he and Kurt but
have grown leaps and bounds like I
disagree I think he's just
sleep-deprived at this point what do you
guys think having purple growing leaps
and bounds I love how open and honest we
can be with each other I just drink
every time Colton's confused I even use
a nap okay so curtain and curtain skirt
button : celebrity name it's actually
pretty good
he's like Colton Cassie Schlemmer name
would just be Tassie still Colton and
Hanna would be Kanna can I get a star as
one reference yes you can coordinate
kirpa go diving deep I really want to
dive deeper with the kirpa because
they're far from the shallow now
[Music]
[Applause]
back to : karpas dates and I'm so glad
we are at a market because I was worried
we wouldn't get another market in this
episode also I'm drinking champagne
today to celebrate the Grammys because
Lady Gaga performed shallow there what
did you guys think of it the fun as it
is very different but because we are
seeing Lady Gaga performed shallow not
highly performing shallow and also at
the Oscars we're going to have Lady Gaga
and Bradley to get the Modena Bradley at
the Grammys because Bradley was the
Baptist and so it couldn't be the Shiloh
that we wanted to be which is Lady Gaga
and brother because he's not there so he
has to give us something different
because she's an artist and she doesn't
disappoint this is really getting to me
right now
South care so accept this rose carpet
have a good chat at dinner though and he
gives her the rose also known as an
exclusive membership so you can buy the
biggest bag of tortilla chips of your
life today's date with kirpa was exactly
what we needed
what did you guys think of kirpa and
coulton curtains convo I was fine
back to the ladies Demi is standing at a
mirror and Demi's hair is overwhelming I
don't know if it's gotten longer because
we've been filming but it is quite long
she is Rapunzel and Demi decides that
she is gonna go see Colton where we
learned that she calls him Koko okay
hopefully after tonight
Colton won't be the virgin anymore the
storm is of ruin everybody the
Lightning's in the bottle the lightning
is in the bottle the Coco is in the
Chanel the Coco is in addition el Lauren
these are our iPhones I know I've been
recording audio messages I know I've
been recording audio messages so that
our head of security Demi a tells Colton
that she is falling in love with him I
am falling in love with you and Colden
responds by breaking up with her I can't
sit here and after hearing that tonight
and put you through a rose ceremony
guys I was so taken aback by this I did
not think we were going to lose demi
this week were you completely blown away
I was but I also got a save mainly
freaking respect Colton I mean he is
making serious decisions at this point
and he told Debbie how it is and how it
is is that he is not feeling the same
way for her self-care yeah this goodbye
was sad were you guys saddened by this
it was real to me the hugs between Demi
and Colton the hugs between Demi and the
women it was the first time I've been
sad to see a woman leave the show this
season so it was a bummer it was the
first real loss I felt and at this point
honestly everyone is like Colton and
tired and confused Demi is making no
sense she says I just really come not
good enough
keep that feeling so you know whether
they you that mean that made no sense
but at the end of the day you are good
enough I hope you know you're good
enough we love you Demi
I love done we cannot wait for dummy to
be on paradise and by the way I just
spoke to ABC exec rub mills about this
season and how ratings are up and who he
has landed paradise whatever war
continue Colton has made his decision
ladies there will not be a cocktail
party tonight whoa whoa whoa not joking
when he told me he plays by his own
rules this season no cocktail kitty I'm
sorry take a moment say your goodbyes
so katie is going home and the rose
ceremony goodbye Katie and I mean we are
not shocked but then Katie also leaves
with this ominous warning about the
other women and how they're not here for
the right reasons
and at this point we've had an ominous
warning from Sydney we've had an ominous
warning from Demi
there's surgeon girls here who seem like
a safe choice but at the end of that
it's not actually gonna be safe now
we're getting an ominous warning from
the girl who we just learned her name
Katie and if you cut all three of these
together it's like a trailer for of
thriller
there's surgeon girls here who seem like
a safe choice Hey
you're not gonna end up happy in the
long run don't be distracted by shiny
things
especially now pulses journey to find
love continues next week on The Bachelor
then tisha and kirpa have the weirdest
little convo off to the side it's
unclear if they know that their
microphones are going still thank you
[Music]
which makes it sound like they are the
ones who are not here for the right
reasons which would surprised me a lot
but you know what never seem every
bachelor franchisee and maybe tisha is
not what we think what do you think let
me know what you thought of Taoiseach
and curvas weird little condo I'm really
losing it at the end here guys next week
ok so then we get the trailer for the
rest of the season and oh my god you
guys this is where things really got
good so much we see more footage of
Colton seemingly quitting the show which
Colton told me in an interview that he
does do he quits the show there is no
more bachelor and then we hear Hannah is
falling in love with Colton and then we
hear : is falling in love with Kayla and
then we hear Taoiseach is I am another
Colton I don't know and then we hear
that Colton wants to lose his virginity
and was it to be the greatest thing that
she's ever felt what I don't know about
that and now we know that Colton fell in
love - tonight I'm finally heading into
the fence to spend with somebody fun
madly in love with we don't know with
who and like I don't know it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot Wow I finished all
the wine today and that's called
self-care award season is almost over
and I'm exhausted and the bachelor is in
the absolute depths at this point and I
am loving diving deep and swimming in it
and I can barely breathe but I'm so
excited for it I love you guys so much
thank you so much for watching as always
let me know what you think of this
season
and that's all I got I don't know I'm
exhausted by by the way we got an
amazing video from a fan and I just want
to give a shout out to her two shots for
the two fans who have been watching Rose
rose day one of them so here's a video
we still love you we know he knows be
gone where variety Domingo you're ready
to make ONGC and guys we love hearing
from you truly like I try to answer
everybody's messages on Instagram I
don't always I love you guys so much as
always thanks for watching and these are
not my sunglasses bye
[Music]